Iran has conducted combat operations
beyond its borders with conventional as
well as advisory forces in Iraq and
Syria since 2015 we've observed this
development by tracking Iranian true pro
tations in Farsi and Arabic media and on
social media
Iran used to rely on proxies guided by
the clandestine could force it hasn't
sent a conventional Islamic
Revolutionary Guards Corps beyond its
borders since the 1980s its regular
military the artash has never fought
abroad that's changed parts of IRGC
brigades have fought in Syria alongside
Hezbollah and Iraqi militias our test
units are fighting in Syria even the
internal security come morality police
organization called the passage has sent
combat units to Syria Iran is creating
the ability to lead and fight with a
coalition of tens of thousands of proxy
forces hundreds of miles from its
borders for the first time in its
history and it's asking Russia to sell
it advanced aircraft tanks and anti
shipping missiles it would give it one
of the region's most powerful militaries
the US must take determined but not
hasty action to address this new
challenge from an old episode if you
like this video check out critical
threats org for more coverage on the
challenges facing the United States
abroad we track threats from al Qaeda to
Iran also let us know what other topics
you'd like a EEI scholars to cover in 60
seconds
[Music]